las miradas siguen estando sobre el mar
negro de ucrania especialmente en la
ciudad de odessa donde nos encontramos
donde deben empezar a salir aquellas
embarcaciones con el grano ucraniano
después de ese acuerdo pactado la semana
pasada con intermediación de las
naciones unidas y el gobierno turco
entre rusia y ucrania para poder
exportar ese grano que se acumula en el
país lo que se sabe es que de aquí
saldrían las embarcaciones guiadas por
embarcaciones ucranianas para saltar
esas minas que están sembradas en el mar
negro y luego pasarían a turquía siempre
con la intermediación de las naciones
unidas- y turquía sin embargo hay
grandes interrogantes sobre lo que pueda
pasar recordemos que hace cuatro días el
puerto de odessa era atacado por las
fuerzas rusas y las aseguradoras no
están seguras de que moscú vaya a
cumplir su palabra así que las
expectativas siguen estando también en
este país donde el sector agro agrícola
y quienes exportan están a la
expectativa de saber si esta promesa va
a ser cumplida todo en una ciudad que
más o menos ha ido regresando a la
normalidad de las últimas semanas
tarde la incertidumbre y de que es
atacada con cierta frecuencia uno de
ellos ayer en uno de los lugares
cercanos a odessa donde está en las
cercanías a la playa